Hello, and welcome to Unreal Engine's training for non-developers.
Today we want to cover a few different areas to just give you a good overview of what Unreal
Engine is, what kind of terminology we refer to whenever you're working in the collaborative
teams.
We're going to talk about using the Unreal Editor and where you can find certain features
and functionality.
We'll also talk about how assets and sub-editors are handled, whether it be through the rendering
pipeline, animations and sequencer, which is Unreal's cinematic tool.
I will be talking about other additional tools that are also in the engine.
And then we'll be diving into Blueprints.
Blueprints is just a visual scripting language which uses code concepts from C++, but it's
just a more visual way of communicating the moment to moment interactions inside of Unreal
Engine.
So let's get started.